[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kphd here happy
new year and i'm excited for 2019 tech
and i tweeted that a little while ago uh
some people were asking what's so
exciting about 2019 why not 2018 tech
what's the big deal but it just seems
like there's a lot of stuff on the
horizon that's highly anticipated at
least that i'm looking forward to a lot
so this video is all those things in one
place and who knows maybe we can look
back on this video in a couple months
and see if any of these things or all
these things actually happen so number
one that first thing is the samsung
galaxy s10 both as a whole phone overall
and also specifically that that punch
out whole pole cut display so i said in
the smartphone awards that a lot of the
most interesting designs and innovation
that we saw in smartphones in 2018 came
from trying to go full screen bezel-less
and also avoid the notch and that's
where we got these crazy like mechanical
things the sliders and pop-ups and all
that and in 2019 i think there's going
to be a lot more of that but samsung has
a lot of hype for the galaxy s10
because it looks like they're basically
going to be the one manufacturer that in
their flagship devices has managed to
keep the headphone jack
and avoid the notch
through 2018 and 2019. and the way
they'll do it is with this punch out
display so we've seen tons of renders
now and concepts of what we're expecting
which is a single front-facing camera
hole punch cut out for the galaxy s10
and dual front-facing cameras for the
galaxy s10 plus and samsung's talked
about this on stage before they they
call it the infinity o display
so i don't know if you want to call it
that i'll probably never say those words
again but it's really curious to me i i
think it's actually not that
dramatically different from a notch just
because the pixels around those cutouts
are not really useful it's not like
you're putting like the time or your
battery or some information up there
it's basically useless pixels up there
still but it looks visually different
from a notch because it still lights up
so
while it's technically
still a notch it's different i don't
know it's kind of a genius play and i
think it's not only samsung we're going
to see doing this but there are others
there's already a huawei phone that does
it and i think early in the year we're
probably going to see three or four
other phones instantly start to do this
and i also kind of wish it was in the
middle
i might maybe i'm the only one i think
maybe if samsung doesn't do it someone
else will but the hole punch cut out
infini you know the thing that they're
doing with the screen i find that really
interesting and i hope to see some other
versions of it but generally smartphone
innovation on the way to the galaxy s10
is really exciting which brings me to
the number two thing i'm looking forward
to which is specifically the new iphone
there's a bunch more reasons for that
number one being i mean it's that tick
tock sort of innovation style where this
is a big upgrade year we had 10 then we
had 10 s now we're gonna have 11 i guess
and iphone 11 is pretty promising and a
lot of this for me is specifically
because of how much i like the new ipad
pro i think that was actually legit my
favorite piece of tech introduced in
2018 i like it that much um so that has
me with all these high hopes for the
iphone so i'm not so secretly hoping
that the new iphone has that like really
industrial boxy sort of design i'm also
hoping that maybe this is the first year
that we get 120 hertz display in the
iphone just like we have in the ipad
pros i am hoping that maybe we also get
a usb type-c port in the new iphone if
they're willing to do it on the ipad
maybe they're willing to do it in the
iphone i don't know and then naturally
we've come to expect high-end
performance in iphones a lot of people
don't know this but the one terabyte
ipad pro has six gigs of ram maybe we'll
see a high-end terabyte iphone 11 with a
six gigs of there's all these these
things that i see in the ipad pro that i
want in the iphone and i also realize
i'm definitely setting myself up for
major disappointment here because
there's no way most of these things
happen but nevertheless that's another
fun i'm looking forward to and then just
all the other unique smartphone things
that we're expecting to see we just got
those foldable smartphone announcements
i made a whole video about the possible
applications of that that could be cool
and just everyone else trying to find
ways to differentiate themselves
and maybe not have a notch maybe this
next pixel not having a notch will make
me really happy too and then the mac pro
the long overdue upgrade of this little
trashcan machine here that apple
promised that they're going to do now
the weird thing that apple keeps doing
is before they upgrade something that's
long overdue just like this they
continue selling it for full price
in the apple store you should not buy
this mac pro right now but you can right
now if you want to but apple in a very
rare fashion because they never do this
before a product is announced but
they've they've promised a full-size
real modular desktop mac pro
and i am really excited for that and
this is mostly coming from the video
editor maker side of me that you know
i've been using the imac pro for the
better part of the last year and it's
been amazing it's a you know 18 core
xeon chip 128 gigs of ram it's got a
four terabyte ssd renders are fast
performance is excellent it's amazing
but it's not a full-size desktop and
it's not modular and i can never upgrade
it and also like reaching around the
back to the ports behind it trying to
plug stuff in is kind of a pain too
minor detail but a new
tower mac pro if they decide to make it
that but basically a full-size modular
desktop will let me try out different
video cards try out different internal
parts add internal parts all these
different things that you haven't been
able to do with a desktop mac in a very
long time has me really excited and
there's also the small small possibility
of them also launching
a monitor like a pro monitor to go with
it i used to be for the longest time a
dual monitor person
and i want to be a dual monitor person
but there's just no monitor that you can
put next to an imac pro
that looks right it just doesn't seem to
match up so if they launch that new
desktop mac pro i will definitely be
using dual monitors again and maybe
they'll make a monitor too and then just
generally there's electric cars
that's sort of a big banner that's not
any one specific product but i think
starting at ces which is
that's next week
ces is next week wow
uh so starting at ces there's going to
be most likely a lot of electric cars
and sort of throughout the arc of the
year we'll start to see more and more
manufacturers electrifying versions of
their cars maybe even their whole
lineups and that's kind of a big reason
why i started the autofocus series is so
we can look into that and see if they're
actually any good also this year we're
expecting to see
tesla model y
the the announcement the reveal
something like that seeing what it's
made of the design it's sort of the the
tesla model 3 of the suv world and that
would also complete their s3 xy lineup
for 2018. they'll probably go through
production hell again for that but
definitely worth it and maybe they'll
test drive roadsters maybe probably not
but maybe but then last but not least is
ces
out there in las vegas next week which
is crazy um basically the best thing you
guys can do is if you see articles or
things that you're interested in that
are at ces i'll be out there tweet them
at me i'll see if i can find him i'll be
out there with a camera so i can point
the camera at it and see if it's
actually worth its salt there's gonna be
electric car stuff gaming stuff uh
probably a lot of vaporware that'll
never come to fruition but still cool to
look at just because that's the kind of
tech that shows up at ces but yeah that
there's just a lot of stuff on the
horizon worth looking forward to that
should be exciting for 2019 tech i i was
going to put 5g on this list but i'm not
as optimistic that that's a 2019 thing
some manufacturers have committed to it
but i think that's a little further out
also i was gonna say air power but
i think as many times as we joke about
that it's probably never gonna come out
ever but let me know which of the things
we talked about in this video you're
most excited about again for me
personally it's probably that new mac
pro either way thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one
peace